[Música]
é
ae
[Música]
deixam o ny
e aí galera seu canal tudo com você e
está tudo ótimo e se a barba crescer
sabendo aqui é barba isso aqui é só um
pouquinho pra faz parte do morro do
vídeo essa barriguinha que eu chamo de
barba dá risada guerra que a barba que
sempre que a pessoa vai comentar dela
depois em uma risada e aí ela matar essa
barba que deixei crescer e eu assistindo
filme eu pensava que eu em 2011 ano eu
ia até a área imensa esse é o filme que
luddy a gente humilde filme com 16 anos
ela para de braço medonha os ombros
largos para se fazer natação a bárbara
maria país vai trabalhar papai noel no
shopping olha eu com 21 é a merda olha
bosta 1 21 horas a desgraça essa bosta
isso aqui pra minha nossa senhora é um
derby é 21 anos agora que vai começar a
nascer e sempre a pessoa que tem barba
que aconselha a gente o que fazer para
crescer mas sei que ela já cresceu barba
com 12 anos já tinha uma união de 5 e 5
segunda etapa um cortador de grama de
ensino a mulher dele já procuravam acha
mais ele nos cabelos pessoa tem bala
fica na concelhia a juíza não por um
negócio é ficar cortando direto que se
ficar cortando direta a assinar bonita
então vou contar cara aproveitar na sua
cara mais bonita é a superstição carlos
é tudo super tição eu sou muito esses
caras que a cabeça petição tem a
supervisão de se a mulher tiver grata e
ela quiser comer uma coisa eo marido não
trouxer para ela o bebê nasce com a cara
daquele ato cotepe manga o cara tem que
se virar para já o manda senão minas e
com cara de manga e vai até domingo
acordei sabonete acordo baqueado pela
vida melhor aquele dia que é dono de
tarde quente a copa destruído tempo a
gente dorme por cima do ensol embolada
fifa quando você tira país que tatuar
tribal na tua cara meu amigo me olhei no
espelho chamei mas chamei a mãe chegou
disso que é esse mãe quando ela estava
grávida de minha senhora que escolheu um
demônio porque eu tava só o supra sumo
da desgraça e tem dia que o carro acorda
bonita tirar uma foto e mandar no grupo
galera é como todo um mito agora tem dia
que meu amigo estava super samba eu sou
muito negócios pet só matam isso eu
assisti o enterro de madrugada e de
madrugada é o seguinte quando você
assiste a um filme de terror
geralmente ele começa a 11 horas e ele
acaba depois da meia-noite e bate rebate
recherche chef michel marie droga e eu
aqui eu tô confiantes embora pai filme
de terror
madrugadinha
baseado em fatos reais e os 16 e 17 anos
para frente eu já morava sozinho você
morar sozinho você mora sozinho né ali
sozinho
agora o ruim é que você mora só vim não
é sozinho só normal é só com força e
méxico assim você está sozinho na sala e
sua mãe no banheiro é você está ali na
sala ea loira do banheiro está no
banheiro e um filme de terror e começam
às 11 da noite mas termina depois da
meia noite eu tenho certeza que é o
seguinte time depois da meia noite o
satanás ele começa a andar por dentro da
sua casa o filme é baseado em fatos
reais eu trago a realidade do filme pra
minha vida se no filme tiver uma
muriçoca muricy joga sempre mil deles é
sobre isso que vai me matar eu nunca
tive nada o sol começa a pagar bem os
usuários boneca começar todas as coisas
na minha casa bem que eu fico meio de
noites querer se vingar de mim e pra ir
pra cama você tem que voltar da falta o
quarto apagando todas as luzes da sua
casa eu apagava a luz escutando música
de deus era tem sabor de mel e sabor de
mel
eu tinha medo de ter alguém embaixo da
cama então o que fazer eu dava um pulo
me uma regra de olimpíada
ele pensa que tem haver medo de ter um
monte de baixo da cama que terá de ficar
embaixo da cama a informação só escolhe
lugar esquisito né um quer ficar embaixo
da cama a loira do banheiro que é
companheiro tcheco que a loira do
banheiro que fica no banheiro podia ser
uma loura loura da sala do quarto eu
podia ser o meu banheiro e nem a loira
do badminton não podia ser outra coisa
que minha mãe certeza quebrava paulo
essa loira da cozinha de estreia que
entregou a supertição pesado eu tenho um
amigo que ele só tem o celular depois
que a ligação está com 6 segundos é uma
expressão dele é uma coisa dele e na
hora que o cara tá chegando eu falei com
ele na hora eu falo eu vou deixar ele
seis segundos perante a aprender um dois
três quatro ou cinco da manhã é da oi
galera aí valeu pai na manhã de ontem à
noite também espero ter esta época muito
mas sei que enquanto estava chamando
antes de atender já aparecia a cara
desse teste aqui ele me liga no seu
entender já aparecia aqui como é que ele
faz isso aqui é um aplicativo chamado
que a google lançou chama google doou a
pessoa liga já com a câmera ativada já
consigo ver ela antes de atender esse é
um ligar ele já consegue ver é atender
toda pra você ficar fazendo
brincadeirinhas e até aí né e dançar sem
lavar alguma coisa ou até fazer sinal de
que é urgente atende que é urgente meu
deus estou desesperada muito mais
pausado não vai usar na hora do almoço
ainda o liga penso eu manterei de um
feijão também do mundo dos negócios pet
samba em um escort bester ayew e santa
você ter um ano novo feliz você tem
pular as sete ondinhas no mar sempre que
eu possa virar do ano em bom jesus no
piauí o dia que eu achar uma em bom
jesus até a cor da calcinha tem gente
que fala mulher tem que escolher a cor
da calcinha para poder saber que você
quer em seu ano novo olha amarela
dinheiro assim é branca é muita paz
calcinha vermelha é amor um mito estado
está a arranjar um namorado né eu quero
muito é paz 2017 eu quero paz forte
porque hoje porque não fica vermelho
calcinha branca né vermelha vale a
mulher menstrua em agosto perto eu não
consigo entender é do chinelo virada
a lenda que seu filho estiver virado a
mãe morre aí ó ó eu todos eles e
naturalistas operção fao de chinelo
o sino toca na hora o cachorro late
imagine um filho valor da mãe
sua mãe morreu
quero ficar assim não e ainda lembra a
última palavra que mamãe bid ficar
ela disse que ela descanse menino
diferente chinelo e nada a ver porque
senão os filhos conseguir se vingar da
mãe mas é agora a hora da verdade é hora
da vingança e vingança
dói é hora da vingança muito isso vamos
conversar vamos conversar não manhã
aguento mais
amanhã o dia deve receber bateu com o
mesmo dinheiro que eu direi que salvaram
scott no chão e sabe como vamos
conversar vamos conversar
desculpa não é igual à que se você tiver
gostar desse vídeo clique em gostei aqui
no youtube volta lá no meu facebook eu
postei vídeo novo superstições você vai
clicar em curtir lá pra gente bater
recorde de curtidas e nos comentários do
facebook marca seus amigos que acredita
em superstição aqueles comentários no
youtube eu quero que você comete com a
superstição aqui no youtube está comigo
é a superstição que você acredita o que
tem aí pela sociedade brasil é um país
muito grande e de cultura talvez tenha
superstições na sociedade que eu não
conheça o momento e eu estava lá e se
meu twitter é esse
o inep é esse tamo junto é nós valeu em
berlim em ti ti ti